ja zur vermögenssteuer nein zur
schuldenbremse beschließe die spd und
will dafür das grundgesetz ändern fabrik
in flammen das feuer in neu delhi
überrascht die arbeiter im schlaf
dutzende kommen ums leben
und handball frauen auf erfolgskurs
mit dem sieg gegen mit favorit
niederlande kommt das deutsche team der
wm medaillen er
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster und damit herzlich
willkommen bei heute am zweiten advent
sport gibt es auch den hut wieder
kristin otto dabei flott gebündelt guten
abend zum abschluss ihres parteitags
fordert die spd die wiedereinführung der
vermögenssteuer allerdings erst ab einem
vermögen von 2 millionen euro
zuvor hatte sie in abkehr von der agenda
2010 von ex kanzler schröder ein neues
sozialstaats konzept beschlossen um ein
linkes profil zu schärfen soll unter
anderem ein bürgergeld mit weniger
sanktionen hartz4 ablösen
der mindestlohn soll auf bis zu 12 euro
steigen
höhere co2 abgaben sollen den
klimaschutz voranbringen und um alles zu
finanzieren will die spd investieren und
die schuldenbremse deutlich locker saß
bohnsack und andreas huppert berichten
drei tage in dem die spd alte zöpfe
abgeschnitten und neue köpfe gewählt hat
drei tage in denen sich die partei auf
einen neuen kurs einschwören
die spd rückt wieder weiter nach links
wir werden dafür sorgen dass der
sozialstaat wieder an der seite der
menschen steht dass er wieder motor des
gesellschaftlichen aufschwungs ist und
das gemeinwohl wieder zum maß aller
dinge wird zum gemeinwohl gehört für die
genossen die wiedereinführung der
vermögenssteuer höhere staatliche
investitionen und die abkehr von hartz 4
zeigen wir haben ein neues führungs
nicht nur neues führungsduo sondern
insgesamt eine neue parteispitze die für
eine linken klaren sozialdemokratischen
kurs stehen haben insbesondere was die
soziale kompetenz angeht wieder ganz
deutlich kontur gewonnen und können
damit glaube ich auch wieder menschen
ansprechen und überzeugen die spd bis
heute eine neue spd und ich freue mich
darauf in dieser neuen spd jetzt aktiv
zu sein
die seele der parteibasis zu streicheln
ist das eine das andere ob die spd
irgendeine ihrer forderung in der großen
koalition durchsetzen kann dass man in
einer demokratie kompromisse schließen
muss das bleibt ja nicht aus aber es
darf nicht dahin führen dass man nicht
mehr weiß was ist denn die spd ich
glaube das wollen die menschen und
wir wollen wir uns stück beitragen ihnen
die neue zeit will die spd eine partei
in schwerem fahrwasser
es bleibt abzuwarten ob ein linkes
profil auf der einen seite die spaltung
der partei überwinden kann und auf der
anderen seite wahl erfolge beschert die
union reagiert unterschiedlich auf die
politische neuausrichtung des
koalitionspartners cdu chefin kramp
karrenbauer lehnt es ab das klimapaket
nachzuverhandeln das sagte sie der bild
am sonntag
cdu-vize lasche zeigt sich dagegen beim
co2 preis verhandlungsbereit
zwei tage nach der tödlichen
prügelattacke in augsburg sind sechs
verdächtige festgenommen worden
sie sollen zwei ehepaare attackiert
haben ein 49 jähriger mann wurde von
einem schlag am kopf getroffen und erlag
im rettungswagen seinen verletzungen
der 17 jährige hauptverdächtige wurde in
augsburg geboren und hat neben der
deutschen zwei weitere
staatsangehörigkeiten weder
massendemonstration noch der fulminante
sieg bei den kommunalwahlen haben die
demokratiebewegung in hongkong ihren
zielen näher gebracht
die pickel treue regierung weicht keinen
schritt zurück sechs monate nach beginn
der protestwelle kamen heute
hunderttausende zur größten
demonstration seit wochen ulf röller
berichtet ein lichtermeer zieht sich
durch die innenstadt hongkongs die
straßenschluchten der millionenmetropole
sind mitmenschen vollgestopft
nach monaten hatte peking treue
hongkonger regierung wieder eine
demonstration zugelassen
die bürger wollen zeigen dass die
demokratiebewegung nichts von ihrer
kraft verloren hat mit großen buchstaben
schreiben sie widerstand bis zum sieg
ich bin wirklich überrascht dass nach so
vielen monaten des protests immer noch
so viele menschen gekommen sind und
heute ist es auch noch richtig kalt die
polizei blieb im hintergrund elf
festnahmen zwar aber keine größeren
kämpfe die demonstranten wissen dass die
straßenschlachten dem ruf der bewegung
geschadet haben
sie hoffen aber auf internationale
unterstützung
die schwarz gekleideten sogenannten von
kleiner der demonstranten hielten sich
deshalb zurück wir haben keine angst zu
kämpfen wir haben nicht vor krawalle
anzufangen aber wir sind sehr gut
vorbereitet
die hand als symbol für die fünf
forderungen die wichtigste eine
unabhängige untersuchung der
polizeigewalt
erst wenn sie erfüllt sind wollen sie
aufhören zu marschieren
mangelhafte brandschutz keine
notausgänge alte electric immer wieder
es ist diese mischung die zur
schrecklichen unglücken in indischen
fabriken führt mehr als 40 menschen
fehlen in neu delhi einen brand zum
opfer
wanderarbeiter die in dem verwinkelten
altstadt gebäude geschlafen hatten
thomas konsum grauer rauch über einem
gewirr aus gebäuden gassen gängen hinter
diesen fenstern eine fabrik
rettungskräfte kämpfen sich durch
finstere verwinkelte verschläge
verletzte kommen in motor rikschas zu
eng hier für krankenwagen und für
leichen transporte in der fabrik
schliefen einige menschen sie sind wohl
gar nicht erst aufgewacht und erstickt
schuften und schlafen am gleichen ort
das schicksal vieler wanderarbeiter in
neu delhi sie kommen oft von weither vom
land nun sind ihre angehörigen gekommen
mohammed elias hat in den flammen seinen
bruder verloren
wir sind arme leute er hat hier fünf
monate jacken genäht für die
wintersaison arbeiten im akkord gespart
wird an allem
ursache des unglücks und ein kurzschluss
gewesen sein
ungesicherte kabel hängen herum kaum
belüftung fehlende fluchtwege kein
brandschutz und kein einzelfall in
indien erst ende oktober brannte eine
fabrik zwölf menschen kamen ums leben
ungewiss wie viele tote noch geborgen
werden sicher scheint nur dieses unglück
wird wohl nicht das letzte gewesen sein
in der ost ukraine herrscht seit fünf
jahren krieg morgen soll ein
gipfeltreffen in frankreich dem
friedensprozess neues leben einhauchen
schon heute protestierten in kiew
tausende sie fürchten zugeständnisse an
moskau dass die prorussischen
separatisten unterstützt die
kontrollieren derzeit das grenzgebiet
zwischen der ukraine und russland
hier will die kontrolle zurück ja und
jetzt zum wintersport nissen war richtig
viel los heute zwei deutsche weltcup
siege für snowboarderin ramona
hofmeister im ersten
parallel-riesenslalom dieser saison in
russland und für axel jung überraschend
im skeleton in lake placid noch nicht
ganz so rund läuft im biathlon und bei
den kombinierern podestplatz für den
deutschen kombinierer vinzens geiger
rechts beim weltcup in lillehammer
geiger dritter hinter norwegens rieber
und dessen teamkollegen chrobok die
norweger mit vorteilen beim springen und
stellt vor allem die länge bei den
absprung da kommt der bums mehr sprung
von von den norweger aber mit dem
fünften sieg im fünften weltcup die
deutschen mit riesling frenzel auf 4 und
5 verbessert dominant aber derzeit die
norweger ähnliches bild beim biathlon in
östersund gewinnen die norwegerinnen vor
der schweiz und schweden die deutsche
staffel mit karolin horchler denise
herrmann vanessa hinz und franziska
preuß schafft trotz einer strafrunde
einen respektablen vierten rang
damit bleibt es aber bei nur einem
podestplatz für deutschland skijäger in
acht rennen beim weltcup auftakt in
schweden
union berlin hat das aufsteiger duell in
der fußball bundesliga gewonnen 2 0
gegen den 1 fc köln dank des doppelpacks
von sebastian anders und verbesserte
sich union auf tabellenplatz zehn
deutschlands handballerinnen bleiben bei
der wm in japan in der erfolgsspur sie
besiegten im ersten hauptrundenspiel mit
25 23 die niederlande
garant für den sieg gegen die
niederlande einmal mehr diener eckerle
zum zweiten mal in diesem turnier
ausgezeichnet als spielerin des spiels
und so zusammengestanden und einfach
werden teams bild der wm-dritte von 2017
verzweifelte vor allem an der deutschen
defensive und einem team das auch
offensiv akzente zu setzen wusste dieser
sieg bringt deutschland dem traum von
olympia und einem möglichen wm
halbfinale immer näher
ja schon mehr als morgen wartet aber
erstmal sehr wir danke christin und wir
haben zum schluss noch das wetter zu
wochenbeginn
und das ist nur im osten anfangs noch
etwas freundlich sonst stürmt und regnet
ist bei 4 bis 10 grad
das war's schon von uns mehr hat claus
kleber im heute journal um drei viertel
von uns gibt es uns gibt's morgen wieder
um 19 uhr und jetzt wünschen wir noch
einen schönen advents